there was a heads up today from Canada's
cyber security agency the CSE it says
there's been a notable rise especially
in the last few weeks of cyber threat
activity by Russian aligned actors
including malicious cyber activity
directed at critical infrastructure
networks Mackenzie gray is with me from
Ottawa McKenzie do we know who has been
targeted no we don't Donna the head of
the communications security
establishment wouldn't give any
specifics but it's rare for them to even
speak with us about cyber threats and
this was an interesting conversation
they had with us today they did
underscore the fact though that there
hasn't been any of these threats
materializing and there wasn't any key
damage to the infrastructure but they
reiterated that threats posed by foreign
countries and non-state hackers are real
and they say that one of the main
countries they're worried about is
Russia and that country was able to
bring down Hydro Quebec's mobile app and
website earlier this morning through
what's called a denial of service attack
which basically shuts down a website for
a period of time but doesn't take any
sensitive data and hydro Quebec was
quick to underscore that saying their
critical systems weren't affected and no
data or personal info were stolen but
Donna this is just the first of many
Russian cyber attacks recently on
Canadian targets over the past couple of
days they were able to take down the
sites of the port of Quebec Laurentian
Bank and even the prime minister's
website was taken down by a pro-russian
group McKenzie Poland's military
counterintelligence sounded the alarm
today about a widespread Espionage
campaign by Russian intelligence
targeting NATO members and EU countries
what are they warning of yeah they're
trying to draw attention to a pretty
sophisticated phishing scam being run by
the Russians that actually looks fairly
innocent now here's one example it's an
email sent to some Western diplomats
that impersonates a polish Embassy
employee trying to get other countries
diplomats to sign up for an event at the
embassy and if they click on the link or
even add it to their calendar the
Russians can gain access to their
computers and Donna the polls are
warning that this campaign is still
ongoing and the Russians are targeting
foreign Ministries and diplomatic
entities including ones here in Canada
be on the lookout for Mackenzie gray in
Ottawa thanks